so how does one go about building a
videogame well at the very least you
need a bunch of talented people an idea
and a hell of a lot of hard work but
sometimes even that's not enough today
on the next big game titanfall we talked
to the folks at respawn entertainment
and asked how exactly this fledgling
studio went on to make one of the most
anticipated games of 2014 titanfall is
the first release from respawn
entertainment but for the men and women
creating the game this is far from their
first rodeo the studio was founded by
Vince Impella and Jason West two of the
founders of Infinity Ward so the guys
who brought you Call of Duty many of
their former colleagues joined them as
well as a bunch of other talented
developers from around the United States
on beyond it's a modest team for the
scale of the game but when we went to
meet them in LA last week they seemed to
carry a sense of camaraderie and pride
it's been almost four years since
respawn was founded at the summit feels
like a lifetime away titanfall didn't
really take shape and tell more recently
what we found in the beginning of
respawn was you know we'd all we'd all
come out of this other thing that we've
been doing for years we assemble the
respawn was literally a day one walk in
and we were card tables card chairs fax
machine printing we didn't even have
computers for it seemed like two months
when we finally got Internet it was like
this big deal we went in the room and
videotaped it a blank slate can be a
burden do you try and reinvent the
military first-person shooter ago in a
totally different direction
what respawn seemed to have attempted
with titanfall is to make a game which
feels mechanically unique but has enough
familiar hooks that invites people in a
difficult no to strike you know it's
about more taking what's there and
what's comfortable what people are
familiar with in first-person shooters
but doing something a little bit you
know we wanted to break the boundaries
we're not not making it completely
different it's familiar it feels like
you know if you played a shooter game
before you can sit down you can grasp
the controls we know what you're doing
but then what can we do now to take it
to another level we really want to try
something really different and I know
when you look at the game if you're
looking at titanfall at face value and
take a screenshot you can't appreciate
what's really going on there so we chase
the gameplay we went into heavy
the experimentation on gameplay and
mechanics and looking at stuff like
old-school quake and doom I would say
that doom or doom - they were influences
the whole idea that every weapon has a
very unique premise and a very unique
design space as opposed to having a
design space where you're restricted to
bullet weapons that have variations in
fire rate or recoil things like that all
the stuff that we all grew up with had
that like insane Unreal Tournament stuff
you know like really crazy gameplay
kinetic craziness and going and chasing
chasing that down and then trying to
find a way to make it I would say like
approachable to get to the gamer today
so that that kind of brought in the you
know using Titans and stuff let's say
the cat Mouse was a common thread and we
explored a lot of different versions of
what cat Mouse even means not even
worrying about Titans or paths at the
time which we didn't have at the time we
have those discussions was just how do
we create this feeling can Mouse what is
catalyst is different things to
different people we want to make sure
that players have different strategies
that they can employ that was pretty
much it and the rest of it was just
trying to figure out how to make a fun
game and it wasn't there wasn't like a
very specific agenda very much it was an
evolutionary work towards it see things
come together see what works see what
doesn't kind of approach I'm talking to
the team it's clear that the prime focus
was always going to be gameplay
titanfall isn't the type of game that
tries to win over an audience with
glorious graphics or a sexy sales hook
it's a game that wins you over once
you've played it but the formula respawn
eventually arrived at came through
months of tweaking and balancing the
titanfall we see today was not made
overnight all the gameplay came first
and then we we just wrapped a universe
around that so campaign multiplayer goes
into that as well but the universe of
titanfall is basically you know humans
have found the ability to fold space
they've found a Goldilocks system with
inhabitable planets out out in this
frontier and people have gone out to
settle it it's not an easy trip it's
like an Oregon Trail kind of a vibe and
you lose people along the way you know a
lot of the surface treatments and
buildings and the environments are kind
of based on this idea where it's like a
Hadleys Hope thing from alien where they
kind of built built these domiciles out
of
containers that came off the spaceships
and stuff but really it's about there's
different parts of the environments that
just feel settled and you know the IMC
is obvious this massive corporation
going and doing dirty things behind the
scenes and trying to keep it covered up
and affecting the people that lived
there which brings on the militia to
fight back I would say the game really
probably started to come together about
a year and a half ago we we had a lot of
cool pieces we had spent time building
you know different mechanics and playing
around with things well let's see one of
the things that used to happen was that
players are sort of tightness they just
didn't start in any other way and then
the idea was that you would lose your
Titan that night now you'd be on foot
and you'd be fighting like caveman
burstiness or soil from that point
onward and you know it took a long while
just because we were concerned about the
design space it tightens on how they
would play but eventually a focus
shifted towards pilots for a while
pilots used to run something like two or
three times faster than they do now one
of the designers were up an idea of hey
what if we earn that Titan what if you
don't what if you start on foot and
after a period of time you get the Titan
so we plated that for a bit and then so
that seemed to work better because now
it's more of an event when someone is
first to fall the time comes in and you
hear that sounding like Oh someone got
it with this game we want to make sure
we had fights like actual I shoot at you
you should at me we don't just whoever
sees the other guy first isn't going to
necessarily just end it in recent weeks
gamers have responded with some
criticism to the announcement that taiga
for matches would be capped off at six
versus six player counts in games like
Call of Duty and Battlefield for
instance higher player counts usually
equate to more exciting matches so why
are we spawn copying the game at six p
six and when was this decision made the
game was never meant to be six on six
until probably six months ago dialing
back that player count a little bit made
the game that allowed it to breathe you
know it allows players to breathe and
you know when you have a game that's
unpredictable and very fast
like what titanfall is you know
you I think players after they spend
some time with the game will really
appreciate the fact that at six on six
might even wish that it was five on five
or four and four because you you can't
predict the way the enemy's going to
come and you can do that in most
first-person shooters you understand the
maze you know where they're going to
show their heads you know the two ways
they can come in but you're never safe
and timely you really are not ever safe
here's a little crazy we had higher
player counts that we played with and
because you know spree start to learn
the importance of situational awareness
and being able to have that right level
of insanity while being able to process
what's going on and therefore if you
can't process what's going on you're not
gonna have much fun ultimately so we
pared it down to a point and we got to a
point we thought this is enough
craziness to feel exciting and dynamic
vibrant at the same time it's not so
much that I can't quite grasp what's
going on or if I'm you know I'm getting
hit from too many sides it was another
unique element of Titan force
development is how respawn have
discarded the traditional split between
single-player campaign and multiplayer
in title for the campaign is played
through multiplayer alongside others
levels are joined together by story
trappings which appear in various places
such as the start of a mission we asked
Vince Zampella if this was a decision to
try and do something new or a reality of
working with a smaller team I would say
it's something that when we started
making the game you look at you know the
amount of resources that you have and
your goals and our goal was definitely
multiplayer we want to take multiplayer
to the next level so how do we do that
okay you look at the amount of resources
that you put into a single-player game
that people breeze through in you know
five six hours or not at all and then
you know the multiplayer kind of gets
you know what's left over we didn't want
that so we said we're going to take that
and part of the goal is if you're gonna
make multiplayer better what do you do
you want to make the world more
believable more engaging so you take
those great single-player elements that
you know pull them over put them into
multiplayer so now this worlds more
alive there's things going on around you
there is you know there's grunts running
around there's no it's just a more
believable world
and all that content gets seen by so
many more people and it gets played for
hundreds of hours and you know so for us
it was just kind of a natural fit based
on our desires and the amount of work
that we had to do as we approach launch
there seems to be a skip in the step of
the people that make up respawn after
four years of working together they're
just about ready to release their
creation on to the world and it seems
they're looking forward to it working on
titanfall and like thinking about it
launching and just just a very short
time away it's like giving birth in
public you know it's a not that I will
ever give birth give birth in my life
but it's it's it's this crazy thing we
don't want to let anybody down so we've
been incredibly hard on ourselves I just
hope that it's a game that everybody
likes and wants to play and you know
tries it out I mean I think we're all
super excited for people to play this
thing I know when we were doing the
Alpha everybody on the team was spending
like their entire weekends playing with
everybody else and just watching them
and exchanging stories and you know we
were had we had to be quiet we didn't
want people to know we were devs but we
would listen to the feedback that people
were going and they would just be
talking about what happened holy [ __ ] I
can't believe I acted I lie not tied he
ejected shot us both up we went into an
aerial fight and it's just like you were
listening a guy yeah you're playing
titanfall
I would say that it's a really really
really fun game with a lot of depth and
a lot of variety as well depth and
breadth it's very it's probably the most
cinematic wild multiplayer experience we
have and I guess what I'm really excited
buzz fact that people are gonna make
some crazy videos you know it's been a
long kind of road to be where we are to
rally the team together get through all
the adversity that we face and get to a
point where we're releasing something
that you know we're proud of and is
being so just it being accepted by the
fans and by everyone you know just so
well it means a lot it's it feels good
that was the folks at Respawn
Entertainment giving us an insight into
the creative process behind titanfall
but we're not quite done with them yet
make sure you check back on gamespot
comm or this week for continuing
coverage of the game including a look
into the relationship between pilots and
Titans and a one-on-one with the founder
of respawn mr. Vince and Pella see you
then
[Music]